my first is an American comedian is
the late night shows from Jerry Seinfeld
the best young up and coming comedian
number this is
you know it's an awkward moment for a
white guy has gone to see a Slave movie
with your black friend that's always
awkward did that a few years back still
haunts me of course we had to see 12
years live in Harlem in the theater I'm
the only white guy in there I'm sawing a
couple mics shaking you know my friend's
like what's your problem I was like I
just want to leave but I feel like I
can't he's like well now you know the
slaves fell
he's like we did 400 years you can do
two hours I was like yes master
and that is how I made slavery about me
looking up for Mark Norman
[Applause]
[Music]
so good to have you on the show hey good
to be here how are you doing good I'm
I'm so short you're short yeah yeah
we're all tall well what do you do six
seven uh what do you guys say
milliliters yeah yeah I don't know I'm
one uh 186 milliliters
no I think I'm six six two no is that no
how much is that oh you're six five we
have someone from New Jersey in the
audience what does
uh each ball would assess tray is
some something above six foot two way
above yeah and you you're huge yeah
you're like if uh Conan was approved by
Hitler yeah
just a little blonder I'm gonna put that
blur up on my next book take it yeah uh
so you I guess you've been experienced
the Dutch for the past couple of days
now I love it here we uh we this is my
like 10th time here I did all the cliche
stuff last night did the sex show where
lizzo went okay I made my openers eat a
banana out of my ass
joking and then uh got some some shrooms
oh really but you you guys your shrooms
are terrible
no offense they're truffles yeah because
I heard some American jumped off a roof
and died so but I got I got I got my own
so I got some real shrooms do you want
any did you buy him here or did you
could you bring him in the country I had
to buy him uh you know
Off the Grid oh
the ones they sell at the coffee shop
sir they suck those suck oh really
because the thing is we're so used to
drugs that we don't really take them oh
really yeah
certainly all the Americans are coming
over and they're like oh brocksburg
drugs and we were like sure tourists
do your thing jump off a roof right
well that's the thing about you guys is
you have your fun like you have the
hookers and the drugs but you still
recycle yeah you know yeah that'd be
very neat yeah you were at the Mia fart
on Monday yes yes as you call it Lake
speed I don't know probably translation
uh how'd it go it was great it was great
I had to adjust to your your Rhythm here
you know you guys go huh yeah
it's quiet it's very you know it's like
Anne Frank but
um but uh then then there's a lot of
applauding which is rare in America We
Gotta Laugh we move on this was huh
yeah all right so so you travel all
around the world you've been here 10
times and yeah what's your favorite
place to perform oh well about two years
ago I was in Wuhan no
um
I've done China I've done Australia New
Zealand oh how was that New Zealand was
wild because they're so detached you
know it's this little island and uh they
they're stereotypes they have sex with
animals yeah yeah which I didn't believe
and I asked the crowd and one guy goes I
have sex with goats all the time
thank you
and I said what does that feel like and
he goes kind of like a deer
this is a weird way to clarify he tried
to clarify with another animal you know
it's a pretty good joke from an audience
member yeah he was great they were very
funny people they're they're odd wow and
I I read somewhere that you sometimes do
meet in Greece after shows oh yeah yeah
that's where I got this hey
yeah yeah what's that like do you do you
really go over the show do they give you
feedback or sure well I think that's
part of the fun yeah uh so yeah I get a
lot of stuff I got a lot of a lot of
hate uh I did a joke about special needs
and a lady approached me after the show
and she said hey
my niece has Down syndrome that really
offends me and I said well how'd you
feel about the Holocaust stuff she goes
that was great
so it's really when it just comes back
to them you know it's when it affects
their life but if you cater to
everyone's life you would have no Act is
is it that's something you play with the
uneasiness that's kind of your style
right on stage off stage yeah I get I
don't mean to I just find that
interesting you know we've all done
jokes about cars and dogs and family so
let's uh go with the fun stuff yeah how
do you deal with hecklers like people in
the audience uh shouting things in the
middle of the show well every comic has
their hey get that guy a drink you know
which means their their sentence they go
to yeah they're safe word like hey some
people have the n-word whatever it is
but uh mine is uh Hey tased that son of
a [__] which you know you get it's a
goofy line you know whatever so you get
a laugh out of it but one time I did a
show in Cincinnati and a guy went up to
the the audience member with a taser and
I had to go whoa whoa I was joking wow
yeah true story and what was what are
your favorite topics to to talk about on
stage
it's always you always return to I guess
I like the stuff that uh it feels phony
like um you know people say like I don't
see color
you know and you're like Ah that's
stupid you obviously do so one time a
guy said that to me and I said well I'm
black
and he's he said no you're not and I
went aha
I like jokes like that you know like a
like a lady will say oh Caitlyn Jenner
is really pretty and I go well you look
like her and I go [__] you so you know
um I I found out that you've asked the
audience to make your uh posters your
photo oh yeah do a poster contest
whoever wins gets free tickets okay so
what well how did it work so you went to
Europe you said make my posters I don't
want to spend money on it myself or yeah
and it gets the audience involved it's
kind of interactive and these audience
members are so talented they make these
great posters and I think we have a
couple we can see oh yeah please can we
bring some oh yeah yeah there you go so
this is like a fan who made you two
posters and and you ended abusing them
as well yeah yeah why not and then you
give her free tickets yes how is that
with the contestants uh from Amsterdam
or from from Netherlands well uh no one
did it
no one no one pulled the trigger on that
one no one no one from from our country
made you a poster no I was a little
crushed I know okay I have a little
surprise for you oh good uh we made one
for you oh come on you want to see it
please here you go
ah
what's this
it's for you
oh can I have it you sure oh thank you
bring it on the plane next to your
shrooms you can use it the next time
you're here I love it thank you so much
for being here it was a pleasure Mark
Norman thank you
[Applause]
very much
[Music]
thank you